pour contrôler l'épidémie le
gouvernement a pris de nouvelles mesures
depuis cette semaine le ministère de la
santé prend le contrôle des laboratoires
et des cliniques privées
alors ça permet d'accélérer les tests de
cause 19
ça permet de vérifier qu'il soit fait
aux bonnes personnes c'est-à-dire celles
qui présentent des symptômes ou celles
qui ont été en contact avec des
personnes contaminées
ça permet également de savoir avec
précision où sont les cas positifs dans
le pays et surtout de contrôler les prix
du secteur privé alors pour l'instant ce
sont entre 15000 et 20000 test par jour
qui sont réalisées en espagne mais le
pays devrait en réaliser beaucoup plus
pour suivre les recommandations de
tester massivement la population
par ailleurs les autorités distribuent
des millions de masques dans les
transports en commun depuis sept
semaines
et pour cause le nombre de voyageurs
augmente un petit peu ces jours ci
puisque les activités productives non
essentiels ont eu le droit de reprendre
leurs activités après deux semaines
d'interdiction
la mesure concerne les chantiers les
industries entreprise de
télécommunications sécurité et nettoyage
toutefois le gouvernement reste très
vigilant le nombre de cas et de morts
reste stable mais le premier ministre
pedro sanchez a déjà annoncé que le
confinement serait certainement prolongé
jusqu'en mai